The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG: You
can pick up the homeworks
after if you didn't get one.
And the good grade is five.
And the MATLABs are coming
in, that's all good.
And I'll have some thoughts
about the MATLAB Monday.
I wanted to say a little
more about finite differences
in time just because
they're so important.
And I got the idea of a forward
Euler and a backward Euler
but I want to give you a
couple of more possibilities
just so you see how finite
difference methods are created.
And then I want to
get started on least
squares, the next major
topic, the next case
where A transpose A shows up
at the core of everything.
So what we did with
finite differences
was this was our model
problem for one spring
and this is our model
problem for n springs
with n different masses.
So this is like, scalar. u
is just a single unknown.
Here u is a vector unknown.
If I reduce things to like,
even this model problem,
if I introduce the velocity,
because everybody's also
interested in
computing velocity,
then the velocity is
u' and the equation
tells me that v' is minus u.
So I have a system.
Better to think in terms
of first order systems
because they include everything.
So the first order
system there, do
you see what the matrix is
on that right-hand side?
I'm always seeing a matrix
that's multiplying [u, v].
So this would be our example
of this general set-up.
This general set-up.
First order systems, taking
them to be linear here.
And then I better
say a little bit
about what happens when they're
not linear today and later.
So this is my problem. du/dt=Au.
And the exact solution would
come from the eigenvalues
and eigenvectors of A. We would
have the e^(lambda*t)'s, giving
us the time growth or
decay or oscillation,
times their eigenvectors.
And a combination of those
would be the exact answer.
So that's the general
method for using
eigenvalues and eigenvectors
to get exact solutions.
I'm not speaking now
about exact solutions.
I'm going to talk about
finite differences in time
because for more
general problems
I must expect to go
to finite differences.
I can't expect exact solutions
like pure cos(t) or sin(t).
So here's my problem,
model problem.
Here is Euler's first idea.
So idea one from Euler
was replace the derivative
by a finite difference taking
time steps forward in time
and use the equation
to tell you the slope
at the start of the step.
Do you see Euler's
equation there?
And that is definitely a
reasonable thing to start with.
It's not very accurate.
It's not perfectly stable.
It doesn't preserve energy.
We saw the answer spiraling
out but if you only
want to compute up
to a limited time
you could use it with a
pretty small time step.
But you can do better.
Now backward Euler
was the other way.
So it's just the contrast of
the two that you want to see.
Neither one is an
outstanding method.
They're both only
first order accurate.
So backward Euler,
this time step in time
is still the difference that
replaces the derivative.
But now everybody notices
the big difference.
The slope is being computed
at the end of the time step.
And that's more stable.
That's the one that spiraled in.
And I would call
this method explicit.
What does explicit mean?
It means that I can
find u_(n+1) directly.
This method I would
call implicit.
And what does implicit mean?
Implicit means that u_(n+1)
is appearing on the right-hand
side as well as the left so I've
got to move it over and I have
to solve a system of equations
to find the next u_(n+1).
So you see that basic
separation of ideas here.
Forward, faster,
but less stable.
Backward, slower,
generally more stable
and in fact, in this
case somehow too stable.
It dissipates more energy.
You don't want to
lose all your energy.
So you look for
something better.
And also you look for
something more accurate.
I want to suggest a
more accurate method,
the trapezoidal method.
Which just follows
that basic principle
that if I center
things at halfway
I'm probably going to pick
up an order of accuracy.
So centering it halfway I took
half of backward Euler and half
of forward Euler.
So is this one
explicit or implicit?
Implicit.
Implicit. u_(n+1) is
still appearing here,
has to move over there.
So if I move it over I
could say here I have,
let me multiply up by delta
t and bring the u_(n+1) over
here.
So I'd have u_(n+1).
I'll have minus
delta t over two A.
All that's what's
multiplying u_(n+1).
Right?
When I multiply
up, let me do that.
Let me make it
easy for your eyes.
I'll multiply up by the delta t.
And then I'm bringing this
part, the implicit part.
So that's my left-hand side.
And what's my
right-hand side? u_n
is going over as the identity
plus delta t over two A.
All that's what's
multiplying u_n.
Good.
So this is the matrix that has
to get inverted at every step.
Of course, in this model problem
that's not expensive to do.
If we have the same
matrix at every step,
if we have a linear
time-invariant system,
well we can just invert it once
or factor it in into L times U
once.
We don't have to do
it at every step.
So that's, of course, very fast.
But when the problem
becomes non-linear
we're going to start
paying a price for a more
complicated implicit part.
What I'm interested
in right now just
to sort of see
these differences,
there's a particular matrix
A that is my model here.
It's antisymmetric.
Notice it's antisymmetric
and that sort of
goes with conserving energy.
I'm not going to-- In
a first order system,
that antisymmetric tells me that
the eigenvalues of that matrix
are pure imaginary.
And so I'm going to get e^(it).
I'm going to get things
that don't blow up,
that don't decay.
So I want to see, what's
the growth factor?
Suppose you want to understand,
is this method good,
what's its growth factor?
So that will tell
me about stability.
It'll tell me about
accuracy, too.
So its growth factor,
all I want to do
is put everything on the
right side of the equation.
I want to write it in this form.
So that G will be
the growth matrix.
And what is G?
Well, I just have
to invert that.
That's I minus delta t over
two A. The inverse of that, so
that's the implicit part,
times the explicit part.
I'm not doing anything
difficult here.
Just seeing how
would you approach
to understand whether
the solution to this
is growing, decaying,
or staying as we hope,
with maybe constant energy.
Because that's what the
true solution is doing.
The true solution,
you remember, is just
going around in a circle
in our model problem
and just oscillating
forever in our model system.
What about the growth
or decay or whatever
of that growth factor?
Well again, this
is the point where
I would look for eigenvalues.
If I have a matrix G, and
everybody recognizes that
after n time steps, what
matrix am I going to have?
What matrix connects
u_n to the original u_0?
That matrix is?
G^n.
At every step I'm
multiplying by a G.
So with finite differences,
you have powers.
That's the rule.
With differential equations,
you have exponentials.
With finite differences, finite
steps, you have powers of G.
So I'm interested in G^n and
what tells me about that is
the eigenvalues here.
If I had to ask for the
eigenvalues of this matrix,
they would be the eigenvalues
of G. So eig(G), can I say,
for this case.
Actually, can I just
say what it would be?
What are the
eigenvalues of this guy?
The eigenvalues of that
factor are one plus delta t
over two times the
eigenvalues of A. That's
what we're getting from here.
And here, this is the inverse.
So its eigenvalues will
come in the denominator.
This'll be one minus delta t
over two times the eigenvalues
of A. That's pretty good.
That's pretty good.
Actually this sort
of shows me a lot.
Well, in the case of
this model example,
the eigenvalues
were i and minus i.
This is for the special
case A equals [0, 1; -1, 0].
This will be one plus i delta
t over two divided by one
minus i delta t over two.
And the complex conjugate
for the other eigenvalue.
It'd be two eigenvalues.
Let me work with the one,
let me take the one that's i
and then there would be a
similar deal with minus i.
That's our eigenvalue of G.
Where in the complex plane
is that number?
If I give you that
complex number.
We're meeting
complex numbers here.
We're not meeting
complex functions,
just we have to be able to
deal with complex numbers.
Actually, when I look
at those two numbers,
what do I see right
away about them?
How are they related?
They're conjugates, right?
Conjugates of each other.
This one is in
the complex plane,
I would go along one, the real
axis, and up delta t over two.
And this one I would go
down delta t over two.
And that symmetry is what
I, the word you used,
the complex conjugate.
Compare that length for the top
with that length for the bottom
and what do you get?
Same length.
So I'm concluding
that in this case
the magnitude of these
eigenvalues of G is what?
So magnitude, absolute
value, is just
the absolute value
of that divided
by the absolute value of that.
It's this distance
divided by this distance.
And you told me already
the answer is one.
The eigenvalues are
right on the unit circle.
In some ways that's wonderful.
The solution if
you compute exactly
will stay on the unit circle.
Of course, it will not
be exactly the same
as the continuous solution.
But the energy won't change.
We're not going to spiral out.
We're not going to spiral in.
It's this average and
it's more accurate.
So trapezoidal method
is like, the workhorse
for finite element codes.
Trapezoidal method is a
pretty successful method.
What's the price?
The price is this implicit
stuff that you have to solve.
So I should say
it's the workhorse
among implicit methods.
And it's simple.
So just to have a picture,
finite element codes
usually are not shooting
for great accuracy.
Many finite element
calculations,
you're happy with two
or three decimal places.
So we're not shooting
for great accuracy.
Second order is very adequate.
What we don't want, of
course, is to be unstable.
We don't want to
lose all the energy.
So this is really a good method.
I have to say it's a good
method, but not perfect.
For linear problems, for my
model problem this is fine.
For a real problem,
a difficult problem
in mechanics you might find that
the energy, you might find it
goes a little unstable
and non-linearity
tends to grab onto a little
instability and make it worse.
So like Professor Bathe,
if you take his course
on finite elements, this
trapezoidal rule-- Many people
have reinvented it.
There's a Newmark
family of methods
and with special parameter, you
get back this one and everybody
makes that choice practically.
There's just a host of
finite difference methods.
I'm wondering whether you
want me to tell you one more.
Do you want one more
finite difference method?
Just to like, see what.
You said yes, right?
One more method.
One more and then, this
is a subject on its own.
But just to see what
else could you do.
What else might you do?
And let me say why you would.
And Professor
Bathe had to do it.
In some problems he found
that with non-linear problems,
he found that this method, which
for a perfect linear problem
stays exactly one, that's great,
but you're playing with fire.
To be right on the unit circle,
if non-linearity pushes you off
then you wish you had not tried
tried for that perfection.
So let me describe a
backward difference.
Let me write down,
I'll call this BDF2.
All these formulas
have names and numbers.
So this would be Backward
Difference Formula second order
accurate.
You'll see, it goes
two steps back.
So here it is.
u_(n+1)-u_n over delta t.
And then there's
another term which
gets the second order accuracy.
It happens to be u_(n+1) -
2u_n + u_(n-1) over delta t.
And then that really is delta t.
Equals Au_(n+1).
It's good practice.
That formula came
from somewhere.
What if we look at it.
What do we see?
What's the picture for
a formula like that?
Is it implicit or explicit
first, our first question.
Implicit.
Because it's using, this
right-hand side involves this.
And if it was a
non-linear equation,
whatever that right-hand
side is, not linear,
would be evaluated
at the new step
and therefore would have
to go back over here.
It is second order
accurate and I won't go
through the checking on that.
And is it stable?
That's another question.
We have to find
eigenvalues here.
Let me not go through
all details there.
It is stable.
And it's slightly dissipative.
It's not as dissipative
as backward Euler.
There you're losing energy fast.
Here the eigenvalues,
the thing would
stay much closer to the unit
circle than backward Euler.
I'll just put up
there so that you see.
What are other features
that you see right away
from this method?
The fact that it involves
not only u_(n+1) and u_n,
but also u_(n-1).
What does that mean?
How do I get started
with that method?
Right?
This calls to find the new u.
I need the previous one
and the one before that.
No problem, I have them.
Except at the start I don't.
So it'll need a sort
of special start
to be able to figure
out what should u_n be.
It'll need a separate
formula to decide.
And it could use one step of
backward Euler to find u_1.
And then take off, now
finding u_2 from u_1 and u_0.
And then onward.
So that's quite fast.
More stable, good method.
And you maybe can see that
I could get more formulas
by going back further in time.
And by doing that I can
get the accuracy higher.
So that's good to see
that particular BDF2.
So that's a backward
difference formula.
Oh, just to mention
what's developed.
So this is stable.
It actually loses
a little energy.
So in fact now both
Professor Bathe and I
have studied the possibility
of taking a trapezoidal step,
which was a little dangerous
in the non-linear case
because you were
playing with fire,
you were right on the circle.
And then put in a
backward difference step
to recover a little stability.
And then trapezoidal
backward difference.
So split step.
Split the step into a
trapezoidal part and a backward
difference part.
That's actually discussed
later in Chapter 2.
Section 2.6 and I might
come back to that.
I just wanted to say
that much this morning.
Having got as far as
forward and backward Euler.
I didn't want to leave you
without a better method which
is the trapezoidal method.
I could take any question.
I would like to devote
the second half,
if you're okay to
just change gear,
to beginning on least squares.
So this was our
kind of excitement
to have time dependence
for a little while.
But now I'm going back
to steady-state problems.
So they're not moving.
I'm looking at equilibrium.
And what I'm going to do
now in the next lectures
is more to see this framework
that we identified once
for the masses and springs,
to see it again and again.
Because it's the basic
framework of applied math.
So now I'm ready
for least squares.
Least squares.
What's the problem?
Well the problem is I'm given
a system of equations Au=f.
These f's are observations.
The u is the unknown vector.
You say what's different here?
It's just a linear system.
What's different is
too many equations.
This is an m by n matrix
with m bigger than n.
Maybe much bigger than n.
So what do we do?
We've got too many equations and
no solution, no exact solution.
I would say probably that
what we're coming to,
what we're starting on
today is the most important,
the application of linear
algebra that I see the most.
So it interests everybody.
It interests engineers,
scientists, statisticians,
everybody has to deal with this
problem of too many equations.
And those equations
come from measurements
so you don't want
to throw them away.
I don't want to just throw away.
I want to somehow get
the best solution.
I'm looking for the
u that comes closest
when I can't find an exact u.
So that's the idea.
There's no exact
solution and the problem
is what is the best u.
And I'm going to
call that u hat.
My favorite choice
of u will be u hat.
So I'm going to get
an equation for u hat.
That is my goal.
And what I'm starting here
just goes all the way to,
there will be weighted
least squares,
there will be Kalman filters.
It's a giant world
here of estimating
the best solution when there's
noise in the right-hand side.
And what's the model problem?
Always good to have
a model problem.
Let me draw a model problem.
Model problem is fit
by a straight line.
So say C+Dt.
Shall I use that as the--?
C+Dx.
It's got two unknowns.
So n is two.
But m is big.
What do I have?
Let me draw the picture.
You've seen this often.
This is the t-direction,
this is the f.
These are the measurements.
So I measure at
time t=0, let's say.
I measure my position.
That would be f_1.
At time t=1 I've
moved somewhere,
I've measured where I am.
I'm tracking a
satellite, let's say.
So I'm tracking this satellite.
Well the times don't have
to be equally spaced.
I'll take the next
time to be three.
Let's say the engine
is off, this satellite.
If the measurements
were perfect--
Does that look too
perfect to you?
It's almost on a
straight line, isn't it?
Of course my point is that
measurements, well I mean,
of course in
reality measurements
would be close to
a straight line.
I'm going to have to draw, in
order for you to see anything,
I'm going to have
to draw a really--
Suppose f_1 is one.
Suppose it starts at position
one and suppose f_2 is two
and this guy will be-- Where
do you want me to take it?
Let's see, if it was
linear, what would be the--?
It would be four, right?
So can I take a
different number?
Three.
Is three okay?
Because five I
haven't got space for.
And you don't want to see
pi or some dumb thing or e.
So let me take three.
I want to fit that
data which is,
we're saying, close
to a straight line,
I want to fit it by
the best straight line.
So the best straight
line would go probably,
I don't know what
your eyes suggest
for the best straight
line through three points.
Do you see I've got three
equations, two unknowns?
That's the first point to see.
Somehow I'm trying to fit
three things with only two
degrees of freedom and I'm
not going to succeed, usually.
But I'm going to do my best
and probably the best line
goes sort of, it won't exactly
go through any of them.
So I'm doing the best least
squares approximation.
And what does that mean?
Well, what would the
three equations be?
What does my linear
equations, my unsolvable ones,
say that at time zero?
So at time zero, at time
one and at time three,
at each of those times I have
an equation C+Dt should agree
with-- So that C plus D
times zero should match f_1.
At t=1 my line will be
C+D*1, it should equal f_2.
And at t=3, the height
of the line will be C+3D,
and I would like it to go
through that height f_3.
But I'm not going to
be able-- If there
was noise in the measurements
that system, that's
my unsolvable system.
What's the matrix?
I want to write three
equations and you're
getting good at seeing
three equations like so.
So I've a 3 by 2 matrix.
And my unknown u is [C, D].
Those are my unknowns.
And my right-hand sides
are these heights, well,
I decided on particular
numbers, one, two and three.
One, two, three.
And what's the matrix?
What's the matrix A that
you read off when you
see that system of equations?
The first column
of the matrix is?
All ones because that's
multiplying the C's.
And the second column of
the matrix is the times.
Zero, one, three, is that right?
That multiply the D. So
this is the same as that.
So here I'm in my set-up.
I'll erase m equal big because
m was only three, not that big.
What's the best answer?
What's the best u hat?
The best u hat will
now be C hat and D hat.
The best I can do.
I need some idea of
what does best mean.
And there is not a
single possible meaning.
There are many possible ways
I could say the best line.
One way would be
to make the, well,
what could a best line be?
I'm going to have three
errors here, right?
That did not go right
through the point.
This did not go right
They came pretty close.
I've got three small
errors. e_1, e_2, e_3.
Those are the errors
in my equations.
So I will get equality when
I add in the e_1, e_2, e_3,
the little bits that will
bring it onto the line.
One idea.
Make the largest error
as small as I can.
Minimize the maximum of the e's
Try to balance them so no e,
no error is bigger
than the others.
Look for that balance.
That's a reasonable idea.
But it's not the
least squares idea.
So what's the
least squares idea?
The least squares
idea makes the sum
of the squares of the
errors as small as possible.
So the least squares idea
will be to minimize the sum
of the squares of the
errors. e_1 squared plus...
e_m squared.
It would be just e_1
squared plus e_2 squared
plus e_3 squared.
What is this?
Let me began to write
this in matrix--
I want to bring in
the matrix here.
This is the error.
The error is the difference
between the measurements
and Au.
So that's what I'm
trying to make small.
I'd love to make it
zero but I can't.
I've got more equations
than unknowns.
There's no two unknowns that
will make all three errors
zero.
So I want to make
the errors small.
And this is the
length of e squared.
The length in this
sum of squares method.
It's a pretty good
measure of the error.
Gauss was the first to
apply least squares.
What I'm going to
do today is Gauss.
Who was, by the way, the
greatest mathematician
of all time.
And here, he was doing
astronomy actually.
And writing in Latin.
The message got out somehow.
So his idea was sum of squares.
So this e is the distance
between f and Au.
I have to begin to write.
I have to write some things.
I can write some things out
in detail, but then I also,
at the same time,
have to carry along
the way I would look
at it for any matrix A
and any right-hand side f.
So do you see that
this is the error?
The meaning of this double
bars squared is exactly that.
That it's the sum of the
squares of the components.
So that's where the word
least squares come in.
Can I just say what's
better about least squares
and what's maybe a drawback.
So actually this
next sentence is
pretty important in practice.
What's better about
least squares, what's
really nice about
least squares is well,
for one thing, the equations
we get for the best [C, D]
will be linear, will
be linear equations.
You may say, not
surprising, I started out
with a linear
system and I'm going
to end up with a linear system.
Actually I prefer to use--
Well, might be too late.
Next lecture I'm going
to put b in there
for the right-hand side.
But I'll leave it
with that for now.
So good point is we'll
get linear equations.
The not so good point
in some applications
is when I look at the
squares of errors,
well big errors, outliers,
really bad measurements
have a big influence
on the answer
because of getting squared.
So if I have ten readings that
are very accurate but then
in an eleventh reading that
is way off and I don't know it
and if I don't realize
that that's way off, then
that eleventh error
will-- It's like having
a whole lot of points
close to a line
and then another point way off.
That will have a significant
effect on the best line.
So you might say
too great an effect.
Depends on the application.
I just had to say before
starting on least squares,
as always, there are
advantages and disadvantages
but the advantages
are very, very great.
So it's an important
idea here, least squares.
I'm ready now to ask for
the equation for u hat.
So the equation for u hat is
the u that minimizes here.
So we have touched on
minimizing quadratics.
This is squares.
I could expand that out as
f minus A u transpose times
f minus Au just to see
another way to write it.
The length squared of a vector
is always the transpose--
Its inner product with itself.
And I could split this out
into all these different terms.
I would have then, some
quadratic expression
to minimize.
In other words, let
me jump to the answer.
Let me jump to the
equation for the best u.
And then come back to see why.
Because you must see
what that equation is.
It's the fundamental
equation of, this
might be called linear
regression, fitting data.
You're just constantly doing it.
So what is the equation
for the best u hat?
Can I put it here?
This'll be equation
that we get to.
It'll be A transpose
A. You're not
surprised to see A
transpose A up here.
First of all because
this is 18.085
and also because
this A is rectangular
and when you have
rectangular matrices,
sooner or later A
transpose A comes up.
So that's the matrix.
And then the right-hand
side is A transpose f.
So that's the key equation
for least squares.
That's the central
equation of least squares.
And let's just see
what it looks like.
You could say the
way I arrived at it,
I mean the short way is
this is an equation that I
can't satisfy.
I multiply both
sides by A transpose
and now this is the
equation for u hat.
And what that did was kind of
average out the m equations.
Because how many
equations do I now have?
A as m by n.
What's the shape
of A transpose A?
Everybody's on top
of that, right?
The shape of A transpose
A is square, n by n.
Because A transpose is n
by m. n by m times m by n
leaves us an n by n.
So we've averaged
the m equations
that were too many
to get n equations.
And of course this is what it
should be, n by m, m by one.
So it's n by one.
It's a good right-hand side.
That's the equation
of least squares.
That's the equation I want to
explain, understand and solve.
Actually why don't we solve
it for this particular problem
just to see the whole
thing for this example.
Just to do it.
So there is A. Here is u.
And here is f. what
shall I call these?
They're mostly called
the normal equations.
That's one possible word for the
key equation of least squares,
the normal equations.
Can you tell me these
matrices A transpose A?
And u hat I know.
That'll be the best
C and the best D.
And over here can you
compute A transpose f?
If I write A transpose
above it, will that
help you do these
multiplications?
Let me just do.
So there was the matrix A. Let
me write A transpose above it.
So it has a row of ones
and then a row of times.
So what shape is the matrix?
The A transpose A matrix.
It's going to be that A
transpose times that A.
The size will be
two by two, right?
Two by three times
three by two, it's
averaging out to get
me a two by two matrix.
What's the first entry of this?
Can you do A transpose times
A just so we see this matrix.
Three.
And off the diagonal?
Four.
And here?
And you knew it
would be symmetric.
And here?
Ten.
And tell me A transpose
f while we're at it.
So that's just a vector.
If you multiply that by
the right-hand sides,
looks like a six.
Is that right?
11, maybe.
Two, nine making 11, yeah.
So those are the numbers.
I can't write those numbers,
write A transpose A,
without asking you to tell
me one more time what kind
of a matrix have I got here?
It's symmetric positive
definite, right?
We know that's going to be.
And we see it.
Our test for positive definite
might be the determinant,
that one by one
determinant is three,
that two by two determinant
is 30 minus 16, 14, positive.
We got a good problem here.
And I could solve
for C hat and D hat.
I see the numbers are not
coming out fantastically
but they would produce a line
that would, I'm pretty sure,
it would be, this
looks optimal to me.
If I rotated any, I'm
going to make things worse.
I think it would look like that.
So that's the system
that you end up with.
But why?
You really have to
understand, where
did this equation come from.
Where did it come from?
It's worth understanding,
this least squares stuff.
So I'm going to try to draw
a picture that makes it clear
where that equation comes from.
So what am I doing here?
Au=f.
Start there.
And the particular
A was, I'll even
copy the A. It was
1, 1, 1; 0, 1, 3,
multiplied u to give
me f as [0,  1, 3].
But of course, I
couldn't solve it
because I don't have
enough unknowns.
What's the picture?
Everybody likes to see
what's happening by a picture
as well as by algebra.
So the picture here is
I'm in three dimensions
and I have a vector [0, 1, 3].
So 0 in that direction,
one in that, three up.
So somewhere there is my f.
Now I'll put in C, D here.
What is the equation
asking me to do?
Which actually, I won't be able
to do because I can't solve it.
But the equation, how do we see
a system of linear equations?
If I have a system
of linear equations
I'm looking for
numbers C and D so
that C times column one plus D
times column two gives me that.
That's how I think of
a system of equations.
A combination of the columns.
Tell me, what vectors do I
get if I take combinations
of the columns.
Well, if I took the
combination C=1,
D=0 I would just get
the first column.
So that's a candidate. [1, 1,
1], I don't know where that is.
Wherever [1, 1, 1] might be.
I'm not too sure where
to draw [1, 1, 1].
I want to go one there,
one there and one there.
Damn.
Let's define that to be the
vector [1, 1, 1] right there.
Wait.
You let me put that up
there and I didn't mean to,
right? f should be zero, what,
sorry? f was [1, 2, 3], yeah.
Damn!
Don't let me make mistakes.
These mistakes are permanent
if you let them slide by.
That's it, same point.
I didn't have the point
right in the first place
so now it's just perfect.
There it is.
Before of course,
if I had [0,  1, 3],
I could've solved the equation.
But with [1, 2, 3] I can't.
Here's the situation.
This vector is not a
combination of those two.
Because the combinations of two
vectors, what's the picture?
If I try to draw, if I look
at all combinations of two
vectors, [1, 1, 1] which
is that vector, [0, 1, 3]
which is maybe this
vector, let's just say.
If I take the combinations
of these two column vectors,
what do I get?
Now this is for
everybody to know.
If I take the combinations
of two vectors
here in three-dimensional
space I get a plane.
I get the plane that
contains those vectors.
So this I could call the column
plane or the column space.
This is all combinations
of the columns.
That's the same thing as
saying this is all the f's
that have exact solutions.
So let's just see this picture.
This particular right-hand side
is not in the plane, right?
That's my problem.
This particular vector f
points out of the plane.
But if I change
it a little, like
if I change it to [1, 2, 4].
Do you see that that would--?
What's different now that
I've changed it to [1, 2, 3]
for a moment?
What's different
about [1, 2,  4]?
Where is [1, 2, 4]
in my picture?
Do you see what's
great about [1, 2, 4]?
It is a combination.
Right? [1, 2, 4] is a
combination, with C=1, D=1.
It would satisfy the equation.
So where is [1, 2, 4]
in my picture?
It's in the plane.
The plane are the heights that
do lie on a straight line.
So the plane are all the
ones that I can get exactly.
But this vector, these
observations, [1, 2, 3],
I couldn't get exactly.
So let me-- In 30
seconds or less,
let me tell you the
best thing to do.
Or let you tell me
the best thing to do.
I have a right-hand side
that's not in the plane.
I can get my straight
lines correspond
to vectors, right-hand
sides that are in the plane.
So what do I do?
I project.
I take the nearest
point that is the plane
as my right-hand side.
I project down.
And it's that
projection that's going
to lead us to the
equation that I'm
shooting for, A transpose A
u hat equals A transpose f.
This comes from projecting
f down into the plane
where straight lines
do work exactly.
So there's an error here
that I can't deal with.
And there's a part here,
the projection part,
that I can deal with.
This is important and
it's fun and we'll
come back to it Monday.
Thanks for patience.